À travers les époques, les dangers, une grande aventure les appelle
C'est...C'est...C'est...l’épopée temporelle!
Narrateur - Ah, 1789, la Révolution...Une époque de grands changements et de grands Hommes qui ont été raccourcis
est-ce-qu'Iris et Thomas vont garder leurs têtes? Mais j'espère bien, je me suis attaché à eux et j'espère qu'ils vont finir ensemble
Ah oui, c'est mon côté romantique...
Lapin - Et hop !
Lapin - Oh la la, qu'est-ce-que ça pue ici
Lapin - Sinon c'est bizarre, vous m'avez toujours pas mis cinq étoiles, ça doit être un bug, non ? Hein ?
Iris - Oui, oui, oui, c'est un bug, oui
Lapin - Ouais, vous savez que moi aussi je peux vous noter, alors faites attention
Lapin - Ah non ! Je disparais encore ! (Cris de douleur)
Thomas - Mais comment on lui met des étoiles, il y a une appli ?
Iris - On verra ça plus tard, il faut trouver les robots
Révolutionnaire - Allez, on rentre à la maison, c'était vraiment une idée de merde de vouloir prendre la Bastille
Iris - Attendez, excusez moi, vous êtes des révolutionnaires ?
Révolutionnaire - Ouais, des sans culottes comme on nous appelle
Thomas - (Rires) Des sans culottes
Iris - Non Thomas, c'est pas ce que tu crois, on les appelle les sans culottes parce qu'à l'époque les culottes étaient des pantalons de riches c'est tout
Révolutionnaire - Et aussi parce qu'on n'a pas de slibar (acclamations)
Iris - Mais, n’importe quoi
Révolutionnaire - Vous nous croyez pas, les gars baissez votre froque (acclamations)
Iris - Ah non vraiment, c'est pas du tout le ...
Thomas - OH MON DIEU, JE NE VEUX PAS VOIR
Iris - OK, OK, c'est bon je vous crois, rangez votre matos et continuer votre Révolution
Thomas - Oui, remettez votre pantalon, s'il vous plait
Révolutionnaire - Ah mais la Révolution, c'est fini ma petite dame, on arrête ces conneries et on rentre à la maison et puis la monarchie c'est pas si mal en fait
Thomas - Mais remettez vraiment votre pantalon là, je ne peux pas vous regarder
Iris - Pourquoi vous arrêtez la Révolution ?
Révolutionnaire - Parce que nous on a des fourches et eux ils ont installé sur la Bastille un énorme canon qui lance pas des boulets mais des rayons rouges qui tuent tout le monde, voilà pourquoi
Thomas - Je vois que ça pendouille, ça me perturbe
Iris - Encore un canon- laser, ça c'est du KB-29 tout craché
Iris - Là, Thomas, regarde c'est la prison de la Bastille, mais ouvre les yeux bon sang
Thomas - Il ont remis leurs pantalons ?
Iris - Oui, et ils sont même partis, ah non, il y en a un là bas, mais qu'est ce qu'il fait lui ?
Révolutionnaire - (Ivre) J'vais libérer la Bastille, moi, vous allez voir, ça va pas tarder ...(incompréhensible)
(Bruit de laser et cris de douleur)
Thomas - Là c'est sûr qu'ils peuvent pas gagner contre ça
Iris - KB-29 veut annuler la Révolution, mais pourquoi ?
Thomas - Tu poses la question à voix haute ou tu me demandes à moi, non, parce que je dois t’avouer un truc, tu le gardes pour toi hein, (chuchote) je suis pas très fort en histoire
Iris - Ah ben merci, j'avais compris, non, l'important, c'est de trouver un moyen de se débarrasser de ce canon laser
Thomas - Tu vois le truc qui sort du canon et qui descend dans les égouts, le gros câble là, moi je dis on suit ce truc et on voit où il nous mène
Iris - Euh ...
Thomas - Quoi ? J'ai dis de la merde encore ? Bon, ok, c'est quoi le plan ?
Iris - Non non, non c'est un bon plan Thomas, non c'est juste que je ne suis pas habituée
*Musique*
Thomas - Oh, oh il y a un gros chat, viens ici ... (Cris de Thomas et de Rat) OH PUTAIN, C'EST UN GROS RAT
Iris - Là au bout du câble un générateur, ça doit être ça qui alimente le canon, il ne reste plus qu'à, débrancher la prise
Iris - La prise ... de la Bastille (Rires)
*Rires*
Iris - Attends, tu as compris la blague ?
Thomas - Non, mais quand les gens rient, moi je ris, c'est plus simple pour tout le monde. Oh, j'débranche le générateur
*Bruit d'arrêt du générateur*
Thomas - Et voilà (Bruit du générateur qui s'éteint)
Révolutionnaire - Regardez les gars, le canon, s'est éteint. TOUS À LA BASTILLE !
Thomas - Mission accomplie, c'était super facile en fait
Iris - Ou alors c'est un piège
Thomas - Ou alors on est devenu trop fort
KB-29 - Et non, c'était un piège
Thomas - KB-29 ? Eliott ?
Eliott - Bonjour, nous avons conçu ce piège autour d'une bonne blague d'humain, la prise électrique de la Bastille (Rires forcé)
Thomas - Ah, la prise électrique de la Bastille, j'ai compris
KB-29 Bon courage. Allez Eliott, on s'en va
Eliott - Allons-y
Thomas - Bon courage, mais de quoi ?
Iris - Ah, tiens, les révolutionnaires
Révolutionnaire - Oh, vous êtes là vous, la révolution a repris
Iris - Oh, c'est pas la peine de nous remercier
Thomas - Ils pourraient quand même le faire en remettant leurs pantalons
Révolutionnaire - Ça a repris tellement vite qu'on a pas eu le temps de se rhabiller
Thomas - Prenez une minute, vraiment, la Révolution peut attendre un chouïa
Révolutionnaire - Ah, du coup maintenant on est regonflé à bloc, on tue tous les riches car ils sont les amis de la monarchie (acclamations)
Iris - Ah bon bah, amusez vous bien. Bon il est où le lapin?
Révolutionnaire - Sauf que, sans vouloir vous offenser, vous avez l'air un peu riche.
Autre révolutionnaire - C'est vrai ça vous avait l'air un peu riche vous
Thomas - C'est gentil
Iris - Ah non, c'est pas gentil, non on n'est pas riche, on est pauvre, comme vous
Thomas - Non, moi j'ai un slip
Iris -*reprenant Thomas*  Mais tais toi, toi, ils vont nous tuer
Révolutionnaire - Alors on a un test en trois étapes pour savoir si vous êtes riche ou pauvre : Test numéro 1(sent Thomas et Iris)
Révolutionnaire - Vous sentez pas le caca, vous avez perdu, vous êtes riches
Thomas - (Paniqué) Euh, ça peut s'arranger
Révolutionnaire - Test numéro 2, ouvrez la bouche et faites "Aaaaaah"
Iris et Thomas - Aaaaaah
Révolutionnaire - Vous avez plus de huit dents chacun, et c'est encore perdu
Révolutionnaire - Et enfin, test numéro 3 : Quel est votre morceau de viande préféré, foie de veau ou pied de cochon ?
Iris - Le pied de cochon
Révolutionnaire - Mauvaise réponse
Thomas - Le foie de veau on voulait dire
Révolutionnaire - Mauvaise réponse aussi, perdu aussi, la bonne réponse était : "C'est quoi la viande ?" parce que moi je mange que des patates, vous êtes des riches on va vous décapiter
(Thomas et Iris paniquent) Thomas - Je crois que j'ai bon au test numéro 1 maintenant
*Musique*
Mes frères Révolutionnaires, voici une dizaine de riches qui soutiennent la monarchie
Riche 1 - Allez-y, je vous laisse ma place
Riche 2 - C'est gentil mais vous étiez là avant moi
Riche 1 - J'insiste, j'insiste
Riche 3 - Excusez-moi, vous pouvez vous décider plus vite, il y en a qui attendent derrière
Révolutionnaire - Allez, installez vous ici
Riche 2 - D’accord, j'y vais
Révolutionnaire - Sur la planche oui. BOURREAU, FAITES VOTRE TRAVAIL
*Les Révolutionnaires chantes* Amis de la monarchie nous oui on s'enrichie finis la vie douillette
*Bruit de tranchement*
*CHANTS* Il n'a plus de tête
Révolutionnaire - SUIVANT
Thomas - Il n'y a plus que deux personnes devant nous, on va vraiment mourir
Iris - Merde il vont nous couper la tête
*Les révolutionnaires chantent* Il nous a volé, piqué comme un poulet fini de faire la fête
*Bruit de tranchement*                  *CHANTS* Avec nos pépettes
Exécuteur - Suivant                                                                Iris - Il fait quoi le lapin, on a fini la mission, il devrait être là
Thomas - On aurait vraiment du lui mettre cinq étoiles
*Les révolutionnaires chantent* Cher Monsieur Le Duc vire la mouche et la perruque fini de faire la starlette
*Bruit de tranchement*                 *CHANTS* Il n'a plus de tête
Révolutionnaire - suivant          Thomas - Euh, c'est à moi
Révolutionnaire - MONTEZ SUR CETTE PLANCHE
Iris - Mince, c'est à toi, non, Thomas, je dois t'avouer un truc (Les révolutionnaires chantent) Thomas je t'...
Bourreau - Thomas ?!
Thomas et Iris - La Buse ?!
LaBuse - Mes desamis !!
Iris - Mais qu'est ce que tu fais là ?
Thomas - Comment tu es devenu bourreau ?
LaBuse - Oh ça, c'est une longue histoire.
Révolutionnaires - On s'en fiche, on veut voir des têtes coupées !!
LaBuse - Laissez moi racontez mon histoire ou je vous empale tous
Révolutionnaires - D'accord, on veut bien l'histoire
La dernière fois qu'on t'a vu t'étais avec mon père !
oui dans cette contrée lointaine et mystérieuse
qu'on n'appelle
jamais vraiment faim est là mes des amis on est arrivés dans un véritable
paradis où la nourriture est servie à foison
*Un révolutionnaire  répète étonné* De la nourriture à foison ? Labuse - on appelle ce lieu le Flunch *Le même révolutionnaire* mais un tel lieu ne peut exister
Oh que si il existe j'ai mangé de tout : des haricots des pamme frites
j'ai même pris en dessert de la compote de *en criant* pommes *émerveillement des révolutionnaires*
Iris - Oui bon et après        Labuse - après le docteur Simon a reçu un bout de papier ça s'appelle
l'addition il m'a dit : "Bouge pas Labuse j'vais aux toilettes" et il n'est jamais revenu       Iris - ah ouais c'est bien lui ça   Labuse -  comme je pouvais pas payer
j'ai du travail en cuisine pour rembourser ma dette mais plus travailler plus j'avais faim et plus j'avais faim
plus manger et donc je devais encore plus travailler   Iris - ça s'appelle le capitalisme
*Les révolutionnaires huent* Ouhhhhh, A bat le capitalisme
Vive le Flunch
*Ils continuent de crier "vive le Flunch"*   Labuse - Oui un piège démoniaque j'ai continué à travailler pendant des mois et des mois
et puis je me suis louer un petit studio c'était pas si cher il venait d'ouvrir la gare rer
et comme votre père n'est pas revenu
j'ai décidé de passer le permis b   Thomas - *émerveillé* Whoua Labuse t'as le permis   Labuse - je suis devenu manager chez flunch je me suis marié
encore j'ai divorcé c'était ma première fois normalement j'abandonne mes femmes sur une île et un jour
le professeur est revenu il était vraiment aller aux toilettes mais il a préféré aller faire ses besoins chez lui dans le futur
parce qu'il est germaphobe ou un truc comme ça il m'avait pas oublié
il s'était seulement trompé dans la date de retour de quelques années   Iris -  Ah oui c'est bien lui ça aussi   Labuse - Pour s'excuser
il m'a proposé de me déposer dans n'importe quelle époque et n'importe quel lieu pour que je refasse ma vie
je lui ai dit tout sauf melun et si possible un endroit où on peut couper des têtes
alors elle m'a déposé ici et j'suis devenu bourreau le meilleur métier du monde     Thomas - J'suis content pour toi
mais du coup tu vas pas nous couper la tête vous savez couper des têtes du matin jusqu'au soir j'adore ça
*Les révolutionnaires acclament Labuse*
Mais je peux pas faire ça on est des amis
*Les révolutionnaires sont déçus*
Le lapin - Ha la mission est terminée
Labuse *serein* ah un lapin qui parle Le lapin - Mais c'est qui ce grand barbu ?
Iris *soulagée* - Oh te voilà toi.
on est tellement contents de te revoir   Thomas - Iris, qu'est ce que tu voulais me dire en fait au moment où j'allais mourir   Iris - Hun ?
Je sais plus   Thomas - Mais si t'as dit "Je t'…..
et après  Iris -Bah oui "je t'…" "Je t' " c'est une expression
dans le futur tout le monde dit ça ça veut dire oh la la il fait bon mais il ya une petite brise
Le Lapin - Non  personne ne dit ça  Iris - Bon on peut y aller maintenant
laisse moi deviner petit lapin, il y a une nouvelle époque où il faut empêcher le temps d'être modifiées  Le Lapin - Exactement, on y va
Thomas : Labuse tu veux venir avec nous ?  Labuse - ça dépend vous allez à melun   Thomas - non
Labuse - Alors c'est oui
Le Lapin - Temporalisation immédiate
Echo
Narrateur  - Ah là là quelle plaisir de retrouver Labuse
ahaha le personnage préféré de l'épopée temporel selon un sondage ipsos réalisé sur mille personnes en france métropolitaine
maintenant ils ont toutes leurs chances
d'arrêter les robots de casser le temps un bon coup de hache dans la gueule ça cale tout le monde à la semaine prochaine
vous venez d'écouter le septième épisode de l'épopée temporel merci beaucoup à la semaine prochaine pour la suite